Gary Gary yeah
morale it just it is Laurel I've
listened to this like so many different
ways and all I can ever hear is so this
is kind of like the auditory version of
the dress that we saw a few years ago on
the Internet in that it's a physical
stimulus that's out there and it's kind
of ambiguous and depending on how the
brain is choosing to interpret the
signal you're gonna perceive an entirely
different way so here we're looking at a
spectrogram of the auditory illusion
itself the Laurel or Annie word and what
we're actually seeing is that on x-axis
in the horizontal direction is time and
then the y-axis is the frequency so lo
at the bottom and high at the top and
you can see that well it sounds like a
voice might only be you know one pitch
there's actually a whole bunch of
different frequencies included in that
speech sound there's a big gap on the
lower side it's not white so there's
definitely some some energy there some
acoustic energy and so what could be
happening is that people who hear Morel
are actually putting another line
through that space whereas people who
hear yanny
they're gonna say that whatever is in
between the two really dark bands is
actually just like noise yeah so it all
has to do with what frequency is your
brain is deciding are important for
figuring out which speech sound it is so
like this is what it sounds like if you
cut out the high frequencies and only
have the low frequencies more oh I even
hear what I heard no yeah definitely and
if you cut out the low frequencies and
you only have the high frequencies
that's the same acoustic information is
hitting everyone's ears but the brain is
then going to interpret that differently
so that's based on the brains experience
with bad phone speakers based on the
brains experience with this language and
also for instance some people with high
frequency hearing loss like as people
get older you tend to lose some of the
highest frequencies yeah I think it's
it's probably good to have some friends
on the moral side just that's right we
all need friends and Laurel places
[Laughter]